[Applause]
there was celebration as the results
were confirmed mixed with the sense of
relief that all the boxers in the Biden
campaign were ticked African-American
voters compos some 65% of Democratic
party voters in the state and Biden
needed their support to help send a
trend for primary stol to come and for
the presidential vote in November so the
black voters in this state are launching
PL for Democratic aspirations in the
presidency and so even though the South
Carolina will very likely go Republican
in the general election primaries are
what matters quite a bit here in South
Carolina for Democrats I feel so
strongly influential South Carolina
Congressman James klyburn once again
endorsed Joe Biden just as he did four
years ago to Kickstart what had been a
faltering primary campaign un and I must
keep working together to make this
country's
greatness
accessible and affordable for all of its
citizens that's what Joe Biden has been
doing for three years making this
country greatness accessible for
everybody and affordable by everybody oh
here Mr President I got to the Delight
of the crowd President Biden phoned in
to thank his supporters his first
question how was the turnout what kind
of turnout you
have later he sent a message on social
media South Carolina we did it again you
did it for me again thank you thank you
thank you 2020 and now again 2024 now
let's go win the whole thing let's win
it all the early and absentee voting
revealed some astounding statistics 76%
of these ballots were cast by black
voters a 133% increase on the 2020
number and even more importantly for the
Biden campaign 10% of these were first
time photos it's exactly what the Biden
campaign wanted to
see and the familiar words are chanted
with renewed
conviction Mike Hanah aljazera Columbia
South
Carolina make sure to subscribe to our
channel to get the latest news from Al
jazer